il est 10 heures du matin le docteur
philippines se rend à la clinique pour
commencer sa journée covage son cabinet
médical à quatre roues tient le docteur
been travail pour sos médecins une
association qui emploie un millier de
généralistes à travers le pays
des médecins qui vont vers les patients
plutôt que les verts oui la minute et
demie il fait un peu extraordinaire dans
la mesure on voit le patient dans son
contact
le simple fait d'aller chez les gens
donnent déjà beaucoup de renseignements
et d'informations sur leur situation sur
parfois les médicaments qu'ils prennent
depuis maintenant 27 ans le docteur nine
fait ainsi des visites à domicile du
malade à gorge un service essentiel aux
yeux de bien des français qui aurait été
aujourd'hui beaucoup de mal à s'en
passer
rien qu'à paris la structure reçoit 800
mille appels par an ce qui donne lieu à
près d'un demi million de visites et les
soins vont de la simple auscultation de
base jusqu'à des examens beaucoup plus
poussée voilà je fais un
électrocardiogramme
cette patiente parce qu'elle s'est
plaint d'une sensation de pesanteur dans
la poitrine et j'ai fait de m'assurer
qu'il n'y ait rien
le grave sur le plan cardiaque le tout
facturé au prix d'une consultation à
domicile soit dans ce quart 50 euros 75
$ pour une visite d'une heure des soins
remboursés par l'assurance maladie
c'est inestimable c'est la cheminée est
trop longue
un service luxe trop cher à assumer pour
un état surendetté
au contraire selon dr neil je pense que
c'est effectivement une médecine qui
était ce économique un in fine et ses
films économique un passage de relais si
la france peut offrir de tels services
c'est parce qu'il ya ici beaucoup plus
de médecins au québec
337 médecin pour cent mille habitants en
france contre 242 au québec soit 40 %
plus le québec fait aussi piètre figure
par rapport à la moyenne européenne
370 la province se classant fait au
niveau du pire pays en europe à ce
chapitre la pologne avec 230
et si la france peut se payer plus de
médecins au québec c'est tout simplement
parce que les médecins français gagnent
beaucoup moins que leurs confrères
québécois en 2011 par exemple les
généralistes français gagnaient en
moyenne 124 mille dollars par année
alors que les québécois eux gagnaient le
double 2 152 mille dollars
même chose pour les spécialistes 200
2000 $ pour les français
quatre cent quatre mille pour les
québécois et ça c'était avant les
hausses de salaires accordée par québec
aux médecins spécialistes
on a tu vois bien comme canada les
radiologues sont les spécialistes les
mieux payés en france mais alors qu'au
québec
leur salaire moyen dépasse les 600 mille
dollars par an en hausse constante
les radiologues français ont vu leurs
revenus chuter
il y a une petite dizaine d'années un
radiologue gagné en moyenne 180 mille
euros par an maintenant un radiologue
gagnent en moyenne 120 mille euros par
an une baisse de tarif imposées par le
gouvernement pour réduire les coûts de
l'assurance maladie
bien sûr on est jaloux de nos collègues
canadiens quand on voit le collègue
canadien on pleure ça on pleure de dépit
parce que on fait le même métier et on
comprend pas qu'il y ait une telle
différence de revenu et cette baisse de
tarif n'a pas pour autant provoquer
d'exode chez les médecins français même
s'ils ont le droit d'exercer
partout en europe et qu'il gagnerait
sans doute plus cher ailleurs
ils restent très attachés à leur pays un
antibiotique
c'est le cas de raphaël chaume ans un
jeune interne de 28 ans qui s'apprête à
entrer sur le marché du travail
après dix ans d'études ma motivation
faire la médecine l epa financière j'ai
eu envie de faire médecine
parce que j'avais envie d'aider les gens
les gens qui nous regardent et qui nous
remercient tous les jours ça m'apporte
aussi beaucoup dire il ya plein de
médecins qui même travail - pour compte
plus de temps avec leurs patients je
pense que j'en ferai partie est alors
qu'en france comme au québec
l'accès aux soins est devenu un défi
majeur la solution préconisée par le
jeune et terne et simple la solution ce
serait
d'augmenter le nombre le nombre
d'étudiants en médecine
en résumé augmenter le nombre de
médecins plutôt que leur salaire